touchy mache middle-class famous tour
update kippy uh-oh we got a couple
alerts going out straighten them out a
little bit kansas city springfield st
louis nashville in the philadelphia that
show sold out already three months ahead
of time we added a second show tickets
are on sale right now then we're going
up to providence rhode island that's
gonna sell out in boston this is low
ticket alert so get those tickets now
we'd love to see you do it welcome to
another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage hey
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find that they
go up to be classy yeah after just a big
old piece of trash
now i'm your host dave trolley coming at
you on a beautiful day down here at
auntie's basement
she's out okay sign up for a softball
league all right yeah doing pretty good
getting out there fresh air stretch the
legs a little bit getting some exercise
mike hose is coming at you from across
the table this is a family episode
he is the ceo of ru garbage
international businessman prince of park
avenue
always the king of the boardwalk as i
said many times mr neptune 2005. give it
up for him kj kevin james ryan what up
yo thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you rate view subscribe over
there on itunes
full video available on youtube as you
know those numbers are
cooking
then obviously i would be remiss i'd be
a jerk off and be an [ __ ] would be a
real big piece of trash
if i didn't mention
i know where this is going
www.patreon.com
are you garbage folks you sign up over
there you get a
whole bunch of content over there i'm
talking
bonus episodes of ayg you get episodes
of hard feelings which is a completely
different podcast where we really let it
all
hang the [ __ ] out that's on the 10 level
and listen
the homies that are watching listening
comment and tell those bozos how good
that 10 level is because it's a [ __ ]
part hey chicken sandwich by the way
everybody keep it zipped also one of the
gripping uh series over there on the
patreon is fat court which uh okay i
star in
you star yes
so yeah okay i started fat court however
what turns out i'm getting a co-star
okay indictments have been handed down
toby
toby's put toby put on 30 pounds
internal affairs got a hold of love
handles over here
[Laughter]
throwing his fat ass up on the scale
listen what's going on porkchop what are
you doing
when you took your shirt off to go into
the lake i was like oh my god i was
looking in the mirror
it's great all right hold on what are
you doing at night
you're doing some emotional eating i can
tell that yeah is it all eating
emotional what are you crazy it is it
sits down to [ __ ] just eat a salad
what are you [ __ ] nuts dude what are
you nibbling on well we'll save that for
my [ __ ] i'll have my day in court
i'll let you know
i'm not gonna be out on the [ __ ]
front steps of the courthouse selling
out my dirty laundry this is gonna be a
closed hearing by the way only on
patreon just so you know when you lawyer
up you're guilty uh yeah
whatever i am oh i'm for sure bringing a
lawyer that's what i'm doing 100
um
listen
i have put on well here toby hit me i
have
i have put on weight obviously you don't
have to go in that close anymore huh
you get an extra wide shot pull back now
to get a close-up on his pork chop
um i do think it's insane
that we are being classified as the
saying to
even in the world of overweightedness
it's crazy to me sure
yeah but hey listen when you make your
living calling someone fat and then you
put on a couple of pounds you gotta take
the heat yeah you gonna take a little
shot my bank account thanks you
well yeah check out patreon so that's
gonna be uh that's gonna be coming up i
have to see my day in court i have to
get on a exercise program i have to get
started eating right and we're gonna
have uh if you're not familiar foley has
to do monthly weigh-ins where we weigh
them and uh
you get financial rewards for um
if you lose your weight incentives so
i'm gonna be doing the same thing you
get back on track over here i like to
hear it have a nice quick shout out to
our producer of shortening he doesn't
need fat cord got a tight little body on
that getting a big old piece from the
word around the campfire give it up for
t-bone mcmuffin
toby mcmullen everybody what up dudes
what up dog uh you're not you're you're
wrong i'm fatter than i've ever been i
know you got a little pot belly
that's about it you got you guys you
have an old man potbelly yeah you have
real like especially when you took your
shirt off at the like
you look like a mechanic trying to
figure out a carburetor he puts his
hands on the back of his [ __ ] his
hands are like this his belly's out he's
got a t-shirt tucked in his back pocket
around like forrest gump on the dock uh
it's a lot i look really good straight
on it's when you see me in three
dimensions it gets a little wonky it is
well you do get your your your
perspective everybody's perspective of
themselves obviously gets wonky because
when you [ __ ] up because you dude
foley was at his biggest which was like
415 pounds and we would see a guy like
like maybe 285 walking down the street
and be like i'm not as fat as that guy
am i i'm like what she's like four of
that guy i say it all the time i go back
to this one picture in high school uh it
was the all-star football game in the
spring of my senior year and you still
think that's what you love no no no i
thought i was [ __ ] fat like so fat
back then like i had [ __ ] terrible
self-esteem i still do yeah
yeah yeah yeah um that's what mayonnaise
is for uh
but
i feel like you put an extra syllable in
mayonnaise doesn't he
mayonnaise
it's real here you put a little flare on
it a little bit of rosemary in that
stuff i stretch it out so you know i
love it
yeah you turn it into an aioli real
quick you find out it's something
different that i'm getting that has more
calories in it now this is mayo
alienates
[Laughter]
double the egg yolk yeah um but i
thought i was [ __ ] so fat back then
oh of course and of course i look at it
i looked at it maybe like this i looked
at it like maybe 10 years after it was
taken where i was still probably no more
than like 250. i see pictures like holy
[ __ ] i see pictures of me and you from
five six years ago
you're smaller than i am now it's crazy
you're probably like yeah 250 or
something it's crazy
yeah crazy wow hollywood that's what
happens the wacky world really yeah it's
[ __ ] there's patreon money goes to
your head no it's not that's all those
[ __ ] pinup ads and [ __ ] tom
selleck and all them back in the day
trying to compare yourself with them we
don't look like joey from friends okay
how you doing
[Laughter]
what are you eating
all right let's get cooking
okay sorry i did have one thing i wanted
to bring up please go right ahead i
think i'm getting a water cooler for my
house
okay okay i was thinking about this
today as well because listen i do bottle
water out of the sink in the winter in
the summer just don't cut it it's not
cold enough it's like drinking room
temperature water so we buy bottles of
water a lot like we'll just because we
live right next to a deli if i'm leaving
if i'm coming home get a nice big bottle
of cold pollen springs that's my go-to
that's what the bird likes as well
but i crushed them and especially in the
winter
you're in the summer i'm drinking like
there's like thousands of [ __ ] water
bottles and i listen i don't really care
about the environment i'm not a big
environment guy what do you think that's
going on that's what i'm doing even if
i'm throwing these bottles out i'm like
this is like 30 bottles of [ __ ] every
three days right in the [ __ ] dolphins
[ __ ] that's no good
i'd love to be that dolphin
what's a guy gotta do
no so i was thinking get that get that
delivered like whatever if it's weekly
or monthly or whatever because now they
got the nice ones you can get on amazon
where the bottle doesn't show
the bottle's at the bottom
so you don't have to do like the big
flip over and dump it
you have to back it up and dump it sure
will it be cold cold and hot you got the
insta hot and the cold okay my wife's
very anti this thing why because it
looks like you work at a used car
dealership well i think it's a tough
look man
you get this little plastic those little
snow cone companies i'm trying to close
a guy on a [ __ ] toyota over there in
the corner
goddamn reports are due by five
i might have an answer for you cause i
was thinking about getting one in here
too
oh yeah but i hate when i go somewhere
as a guest on a podcast and they give
you a cup of water
that's it i don't like a bottle i like a
bottle i just it's not it's cold it's
crisp because like i guess if i could
see it if it was there like oh help
yourself to water that's one thing but
i don't know i just want maybe we have
bottles for the guest and i'll just do
the
okay the water i think i have an answer
for you
with the with the with the house
situation i've been thinking about this
a lot too um i know this sounds weird
coming out of my mouth but i don't think
the like
the reason i i want to get one of those
things is i have one because you copy my
no i was thinking about today glassman
rick got into my head about it um
he
i don't think the water even in new york
city
is that great anymore i don't think that
we're really drinking the best water and
i think the way that you could meet
halfway with your lady is get one of
those [ __ ] filter jones i think they
have where
what do you mean what do you mean filter
john you can get one you can get a cut
it's a it's a combination of of the
water jug
and it has a filter in it it filters the
water so you just put in regular water
no i think it all comes together i
believe i'm so you need you need a water
filtration system is what i'm saying
yeah i was gonna say you should get the
i i have the the big brittle with the
tap on it in the in the fridge it's
excellent
we just we just got we just put the the
cube whatever but then that's even
not though it comes out a little slow
i'll be like yeah i'm trying to [ __ ]
i get this thing cooking here it's a gut
you got to put the hole in it with the
knife at the top like a [ __ ] no oh
you're using that uh-huh
[ __ ] soccer team
what the [ __ ] who uses that which he
brought home yesterday we're not doing
that all the time i didn't even know
they still made those oh yeah oh your
microplastic levels must be fun what are
you talking about the brita like it's
the same thing it's the same concept but
a brita no yeah but it's it's hard
plastic it's good so you're drinking out
of soft plastic there i'm not saying
it's classy but they're the same [ __ ]
product no it's much awesome
that's insane what do you think what do
you think the phil do you think he re
replaces the filter on that [ __ ]
brand no that's all you don't got to
replace that's what i'm saying so it's
the same [ __ ] thing
both are trashy i just got it i got two
backups i'm gonna be diligent about it
good job i got well i'm gonna check in
with you and what how how long does one
last two months i'm gonna check back in
with you and it's gonna be empty
growing up they last about three to five
years
over the pandemic i was i was that's a
recommendation i was staying down the
shore with a brita and there wasn't even
a filter in it we were just using you're
just using as a pitcher i know but in
your head it tastes better
oh yeah it looks real crystal clear and
those rid of things um no i i want to
start doing some kind of
filtered cause i'm drinking a lot more
water these days but then so my wife uh
our friend in the building has uh
something similar where you buy the
glass bottle you buy big glass bottles
like the five like the big but water
quality spring pollen springs kind of i
mean i'm drinking it now but it's not
good water i don't think you're nuts i'm
a [ __ ] you think this is great water
i thought they got pinched a couple
years ago using creek water yeah that's
good stuff
it's got the it's a living it's got
living organisms in it it's probiotics
daddy i don't need to eat yogurt once
you're drinking this hey would you like
to get a nice crayfish in a bottle of
water huh
i like algae i can see all right it's
the enemy you know um
but there so our friends in the building
fill up a big you can go to like a i
guess it's a filling station you're not
doing that stop that's [ __ ] hippie
and i go there's no way i'm gonna on
paper sure but we're lazy i'm the guy
who does it and then never replaces the
brita field i'm never gonna there's just
gonna be four empty glass jugs in my
maybe slashing coins in there yeah
that's that's like a few years ago when
[ __ ] uh hipsters started rolling
around with those [ __ ] jugs the
growlers getting their beers filled up
[ __ ] loser those things [ __ ]
sucked
yeah [ __ ] thing a honey brown ale
what's going on dude those things you're
not going to do that
uh yeah that's why i v you're not a
co-op guy no i i'm i'm lazy i want the
water to come to me that's what i want
deliver it every whatever it is every
month every two weeks whatever it is
i'll start [ __ ] stockpiling i'll be a
prepper dude i don't care there you go
you need a filtration situation i don't
know what that what do you keep saying
that what does that mean i don't think
you know what it means we gotta start
filtering our water more
it's better yeah but if i get it
delivered that's clean crisp water i
don't think so toby can you give me a
fact check on that is poland spring good
water well it can be anybody aqua fresh
leslie's pools whatever
fresh
winter green whatever you got
that
you know what my brother does is pretty
classy for like uh engage engagements
and affairs they have a glass like
something you would put like sangria in
with uh i don't try cucumber water
real nice now get first of all cucumbers
stinks second of all in the water it's
worse because it's just
a little cucumber
first of all who the [ __ ] do you think
you are unless i'm checking into a
five-star hotel
kick [ __ ] rocks with your cucumber
water that's that's what poor people
think is classy we got
we we got hot news on the poland spring
dude they're currently under lawsuit for
claiming the best goddamn water in
america know that it's groundwater and
not true spring water goddamn line to
you i don't care where it comes from
i currently drink it out of a [ __ ]
out of the sink in my six-story new york
city apartment that ain't good for you
no that's what i'm saying those pipes
are pre-war oh they fought the nazi
those pipes so i'm like what the it's
better it's better listen who knows what
we're drinking meanwhile i'm not even
counting but i probably drank about 87
beers last week who am i to judge the
quality of my water
you know what i mean
it is what it is
all right but yeah let's get one in here
okay yeah yeah
can we get a soda machine
that'd be pretty cool what where are we
gonna put it i don't know
toby you're out
let's teach you soda machine how to edit
you know it'll be nice in here as a
vending machine
that'd be pretty cool stocked with
vegetables whatever or pop tarts since i
retired used to buy my bait out of a
bait vending machine
blew my mind that those worms would stay
fresh in there you put them in your
trunk last week and they stayed fresh
yeah i mean it's not a dog it's their
worms they don't they need to breathe
doesn't the heat kill them
he remembered that and right he threw
them right in his trunk and then went to
lunch
yeah i lucky we didn't call the cops
smash the windows and get them out of
there they're a couple of crawlers dude
they're in dirt
yeah but then they the heat can't be
good for them
what do you think where do you think
they are in general they're not in the
trunk of a [ __ ] buick
he's going to stab him with a hook
and drown them and feed him to fish the
best case scenarios that didn't get seen
by what it thinks is a monster
all right
that thing should be sucking my dick
i left the radio on
zeppelin was playing you can't give fish
dead worms they won't bite them they
gotta they gotta be fresh like lobster
you jiggle it they don't know what do
you know about you're not an angler okay
yeah i mean also
sure i am an animal lover
yeah a couple of pigs in your s3 all
right easy does
i won't stand for this
you're under indictment
whatever let's get in we got to get into
it this is a guy this isn't goddamn hard
feelings it's a goddamn [ __ ]
what's the other show we do are you
garbage that's right gang as you know
when you sign on for the patreon there
you could get a question read on the air
right here on a family episode sometimes
we do it with just me and kippy
sometimes we bring a friend back to the
show
and have a little company yeah
um all right this one is just a home run
of a name this is paddy's parliament
patio there you go
marble lights by the way but if you're
not familiar it's in the it's on the
it's on the patreon in the year the
cribs video of your house yes
your mom cranks all of her heaters in
the back sun room type florida room
whatever you want to call that screened
in [ __ ] bernie hut
i mean i walked in there it was like
bernie hudson it was like walking into a
goddamn casino
you leave my mother out of this shout
out to patty shout out to her is it
garbage just stopping in oh this how
[ __ ] is it garbage to stop at an
indian casino on the way home from work
so you can smoke a bernie in the air
conditioning on a hot summer day holy
[ __ ] that means the ac isn't working in
your car as well damn that's the the the
deduction those parking lots are huge i
don't mean that's like that's like a lot
of effort that's like a 45 minute and
you know there's got to be more to that
story
i don't know i do he's
of course
a bernie inside is all right by the way
not a fan a couple i'm a couple i'm like
two months off the three months off the
bernie's maybe nice i've been thinking
about them yeah nah not really i was we
were ripping them last night legion of
skanks
that was all right that's they're the
ones you kind of miss where you're like
the ones that you didn't get to have all
the time
were the good like the indoor cigs the
whatever sings
so when everybody's hanging out inside
i'm [ __ ] you know i got 19 beers in
me and everyone's cranking them inside
that's when you want to be like i'll do
one they got real smoky in there towards
the end yeah those tequila stuff it was
like a card game
i couldn't see in front of you
oh that was a good time um yes but that
is uh that is very trash can't let's
talk about draftkings sportsbook
sportsbooks
we're talking to big dogs in the
building
our boys are in the action already this
year we're in it we're in it early we're
doing a little betting over there yeah
going heavy with the nfl heavy with the
birds i heard today but the house on a
bird so yeah they better cover it's fun
man i never did it before i'm in it now
we're doing it it's it's fantastic it
adds a little spice to your life baby it
adds a little spice to the games man
it's a good time i'm telling you and to
celebrate the return of football
draftkings is giving new customers a
can't miss offer bet just five dollars
on any football game and get two hundred
dollars in free bets instantly daddy
that's what we're talking about there's
the turkey uh want more action for
opening night experience the thrill of
draftkings early win promotion this is
where you bet on any nfl team of your
choice and if your team leads by seven
points at any point during the game you
get paid instantly even if your team
loses
that's the turducken right there that's
good stuff draftking's a safe security
turkey and reliable best of all you can
deposit and withdraw your cash uh
whenever you want here we go baby
download the draftking sportsbook app
now use promo code ayg to get 200 and
free bets instantly when you place a
five dollar bet on any football game
that's bonko's that's code ayg
only at draftkings sportsbook an
official sports betting partner of the
nfl minimum age and eligibility
restrictions apply see show notes for
details do it do it let's talk about
feels touchy feely i love it like feels
little cbd you like getting a good
night's sleep
get your anxiety going down you like
having a clear head just melts away baby
few drops under the tongue that's right
feels got you takes care of you uh-huh
you can feel the difference in minutes
no hangover no addiction i've been a big
cbd guy for a few years now found it
it's true love the little drops under
the thing started out with feels be way
before we even did this podcast i know
they were standing to tell me how's in
doing it it's fantastic just takes that
takes that edge off lowers the shoulders
and a good night's sleep is important
believe me i know i know navigating the
world of cbd can be complicated feels
makes the process as simple as possible
with free cbd hotline to guide you
through the process any questions you
have they can take care of it feels
hassle-free membership program is
guaranteed to help you feel the best
month after month or your money back i
highly recommend the subscription model
uh they send it right there you never
have to be because i used to be like i'm
out i'm out and i go up never mind they
sent it yesterday it's in a medicine
cabinet let's do it uh feel cbd infused
mints give you the clear-headed feeling
on the go ship direct to your door only
a few days feels is a new natural
healthy better way to feel uh start
feeling better with feels become a
member today by going to feels.com
garbage and you'll get 50 off your first
order with free shipping that's feels f
e a l s dot com slash garbage to become
a member and get 50 off 50 off
automatically taking off your first
order with free shippingfeels.com
garbage do it now back to the show
stopping at a casino to smoke cigs i've
got to know more information how was he
[ __ ] does a four hour commute i know
because there's always like some sort of
on-ramp or all that's not just like
pulling into a 7-eleven and back in the
fight yes
this is how lazy i am depending on how a
parking lot is orient orientated is that
the word
i won't stop there no i'll be like cause
then you gotta turn back around you
gotta loop in it's three laps nothing
worse than a big parking lot when i was
a kid i felt like we parked [ __ ] in
the last spot every [ __ ] grocery
store
i was like walking through the desert
how do you feel about this
growing up a friend's dad used to do it
all the time
he would park all the way in the back
away from the other car so the other
cars wouldn't
like hit like you know
wouldn't bump into him or whatever and
he drove a jeep that's crazy i remember
and it wasn't even like a brand new g
like it was like my dad also had a jeep
and it was a newer jeep i remember being
like
what are we doing he parked all the way
in the bed we pulled up he goes oh
there's bob
bob's here because he was like the last
fight that's crazy
that's a that's a flight or uh flight or
fight
thing i think i wanna be able to get out
of here quick yeah but then you gotta we
gotta run a quarter mile to the car that
don't make any [ __ ] sense
meanwhile there's no coverage because
there's no cars around you if you're
taking fight or flight you put it in the
produce aisle i know you [ __ ] pull it
up leave it running out front daddy
yeah that's wild i don't know yeah i
don't do that
uh this one's from ip
oh i'm an idiot
it's ip freely uh
that's a classic right i feel like moe
right now from the simpsons
just getting got on all the phone all
the the phony phone call i hated that
what did you call
prank phone call or crank phone calls i
think we said crank crank calls crank
call yeah we said crank card crank call
hang up
it's a craig call hang up terry we'll
talk about it on hard feelings but i
think i got one yesterday really uh-huh
um
how do you do that in 2022. they called
my wife's phone it was uh what i'm doing
now called my wife's phone it was a new
york number so she answers and he's like
yeah i'm uber i'm outside and i'm like
and she's like what she's looking at me
like did you call an uber or something
i'm like no what
so he's like kind of yelling at her like
he's like being he's like i'm outside
come on right now like yeah hurry up i i
i'm waiting here and she's like i didn't
call the new like what are you talking
about so i get to find out hey buddy and
he's like
i like english didn't sound like his
first language in english is my wife's
first language i'm like let me step in
here and you know [ __ ] really [ __ ]
this
[Laughter]
so i'm like hey man nobody i'm like he
goes i'm here 516 east meadows street
would give you your address no if you
would have gave my
the door i'll addre right there
so he goes what are you doing answering
numbers you don't know she does she
thought it was a doctor or something
yeah you know um
and uh that's in new york it's a local
not even local numbers they're smart now
they got they're doing local numbers now
what i'm saying if i get a local number
i'll answer for the most part a new york
city number now those you got to watch
those 917 numbers but no one's getting
no they're all pump and dump scams
that's fine first of all i don't answer
any call but a nine a new york number
i'm more
likely to answer okay
nah he got no bad history here if
somebody from philly's calling me
[ __ ] throw my phone in the river
if i get hit off from a 267 number i
remember we were driving the other day
and i got a call from bedford new york
yeah i almost drove off a bridge i hung
up for you i said no thank you hey we're
not taking calls right now
hey listen i speak for the big man
yikes so i go hey man
and now he's like yelling he's getting
assertive he's like i'm [ __ ] here i
need my money you better you better come
i drove all the way out here like you
know i guess he drove so i don't know
what happened so i'm like hey man listen
i understand but you got the wrong he's
like he reads the number i'm like that
is the number but i'm not we didn't call
an uber and that's not a hard dressing
because well where do you live i got
enough i can tell you that
i'll come pick you up
for my dead body you [ __ ] idiot
so
he's we're going back and forth i go he
goes i'm gonna [ __ ] go knock on the
door i go all right man go knock on the
door so then like hey
you hear them like walk up to the house
and you hear them like nah i'm like this
might be a [ __ ] phony phone call they
might be getting me over that's pretty
good yeah
i told him go [ __ ] himself a couple of
timber lake tickets after all that
justin timberlake tickets radio prank
call oh you think it could have been a
radio call maybe okay those are all fake
anyway
are they yeah we used to have a friend
that would call in and do them it was
like a gig for comedians like we'll give
you 50 bucks
to do it i would be the receiver oh yeah
yeah yeah to like play along i'll
[ __ ] kill you my wife cheated on me
whatever it is they still make with the
tickets
i don't know
justin timberlake was never even coming
to town the whole thing's
not even touring
um
but yeah crank call what did you say
prank call
crank call pr phony phone calls is whack
that's morning dj chief yeah buddy phone
call yeah coming up uh next hour we got
a photo call for you yeah none of that
[ __ ]
um
all right this one's from omar the halal
falafel farmer as a shout out to oh uh
as a 20 shareholder i demand
satisfaction is it garbage to have a
movie cartoon or comic book character on
your credit or debit card yeah
yeah i would argue anything on there is
relatively trashy they're custom credit
nobody really does them anymore they're
trash i think crap people probably do
the more you think
it's easier it's cheaper the picture was
always weird too
dude it was like a 1980s headshot she
got done at sears i remember even being
like six being like lady i've never seen
this before
you can't make a down payment with a
bart simpson visa oh yeah you're
definitely splitting between multiple
cards yeah
yeah you put 10 on goofy and
20 on bugs bunny baltimore raven's
mastercard a sports credit card is the
[ __ ] trap you're better off having a
[ __ ] neck tattoo of the flyers logo
paying your wife's hospital bills with
that
put that on tweety bird
yeah you're definitely overdrawn more
than not if you have a sports themed
credit card sure custom checks are also
whack not that anybody really uses
checks anymore but that's pretty well i
don't even have checks
checks i haven't had checks and you have
checks oh yeah
well who are you writing checks to
landlord my landlord now it's all online
which is sick yeah i'm auto pay i did
too i feel like such a badass i know it
feels pretty cool i didn't have the rent
i did have to stop it two months ago but
easy does it yeah i'm back on though
nice
axes are some of a [ __ ]
um
but uh
[ __ ] what are you just saying my mom had
the picture i
any of that [ __ ] but they're doing now i
see on like instagram you can send your
card into this company
and they take it and make a
custom like metal card that's supposed
to be like cool you know what i mean
everyone's just trying to have a black
card yeah but you don't nope
we're getting close though no we're not
we're not
to a black car yeah platinum platinum's
that far away
yeah well we are on the very very very
bottom end of platinum we're in the
g-league of black yeah yeah they gave it
to us just by you know contrast some
sort of contractual obligation
that's what you want with the prank
phone call yeah they don't uh
we're we're we're with american express
kind of like you know we're like a
subsidiary you know
we don't have the main guys handling
ours no no no no we got a couple of
juniors on the account a couple of
junior men 350 000 to 500 000 across all
their american express accounts in a
calendar year to qualify for a black
card
how much half a mill 350 to half a mil
yeah
they get to spend yeah
okay everyone's finding first class from
here
you get a house you get a house
um no that's crazy we're not doing that
okay
what does it get you hold on
what are the benefits of that there's
like a concierge service where like
if you're like hey
i'm on that bot you know i'm on the back
end of a [ __ ] coke bender and i you
know i need some i need i need a
location of a good rub-and-tug
they'll they'll hook you up there's like
some sort of concierge i think that's 24
7 contraire service is a black card
holder you can take advantage of the
centurion's concierge service that
sounds pretty [ __ ] sick yeah things i
can't spell all right
they help make travel arrangements
purchase gifts secure reservations at
exclusive restaurants get tickets to
nearly any event damn it's pretty sick
dude
not for free though right no it costs
half a million dollars yeah no but i
mean will they get you the tickets for
free no you probably have to pay for it
okay
was that crazy
yes i don't know yeah i mean you're rich
not just you know i get my own tickets
no you can't he can't you mean you're
telling me if there's something sold out
yeah they have like they have like so
like like take hamilton for instance at
every hamilton show there's
that [ __ ] thing
i mean i'm not asking you to go fine um
there's like reserved american express
tickets oh okay where like they get
first crack at them or something like
that i don't know i'm a miss saigon man
i don't like using all that stuff
i don't only p i don't like i don't get
in bed with people
does that make sense i feel like if i
use something from them i'm gonna owe
them something in the future yeah half a
million dollars
he just told you and you gotta talk to
the centurions
the centurion candidate
i wake up i'm an american express card
good question
alexander do you scour the aisles after
a baseball games for any lost valuables
jesus that's worse than a metal detector
on the beach goddammit crazy but as a
kid when you would go i would go to like
my brothers like or like a friends
whatever it's like basketball game or
something
not even a pro game what no i'm not
you're cruising a little league
that's what you said you didn't let me
finish the story
getting under a set of bleachers as a
kid oh come on
you might as well been a narnia dude
yeah that was a [ __ ] good a hundred
percent if there were like the big
wooden ones that would pull out from the
wall remember how dangerous those things
were kids would climb all the way they'd
be like 35 feet in the air in a gym yeah
with no way down somebody just slammed
those shut
yeah and the gym was awesome outside was
awesome too
yeah the metal ones when you go you know
if it was nighttime get under there
that's where the hanky-panky goes on
a little finger popping it you tug it on
your root
that's like from an old movie i feel
like that's where everybody made it
under the bleachers hanky-panky is just
fully eating flapjacks
we're here please
if i can eat [ __ ] pancakes over there
is there a girl back here with you boy
sorry this is back to ib freely is it
garbage to say this is a different type
of money when you drive through a rich
neighborhood
that's my that's definitely something
yeah it's a different kind of money in
here boys
that's real trash
my dad would always downplay it like
they
anybody can get that i just choose to
live in a split level i guarantee you
they miss one paycheck they're moving
out of that house pay that right now
justify it yeah yeah mortgage is
probably through the roof
sure yeah yeah i remember one time
pulling up with my my step-dad or
something my buddy's house huge
sprawling you know
like crazy estate and my stepdad's like
this don't they they did have the same
they were like both construction workers
like this don't make no [ __ ] sense he
goes what's this guy rob banks or
something
ah it's good it's good stuff um
all right hold on back to the bleacher
thing
you want to go under no as a kid uh-huh
um at like a phillies game i would i
would take a lap or two to see if i
could find the little commemorative
stuff yeah the helmets the little
helmets or a copper or some rich kid
didn't take his [ __ ] sunday helmet
home with them collect those things
maybe a little chocolate syrup at the
time yeah we're still a little soft your
whistle yeah it's all right uh
yeah
yeah i i get that but we were also never
big on getting there to get
like the bobble head or what you know
the first 5 000 people get
a t-shirt or whatever we were like
that's
yeah no we just never [ __ ] did that
we've talked about it many times in this
broadcast there's only one
giveaway
not even a giveaway one promotional move
that'll get the foley's out to any
sporting event and that dollar diesels
dollar dog night yeah shout out to him
god damn it those things are good
in the [ __ ] little tinfoil thing with
the bun everything's moist and together
i'd kill for a hot dog
you can have a hot dog just no bun
that's the point that's the whole point
of the bun okay a little musty i did
have a hot dog
all right had a hot dog camping
sure yeah it was good times
all right
okay
it's been a hot dog a minute
uh speaking of canada this is from tj uh
10 homie never had a q red is it garbage
to reuse bacon fat for cooking
bacon to give it that extra bacon flavor
whoa
that's pretty i didn't think of that
also i don't think you need fat for
bacon no you just put it on a clean dry
pan that doesn't give you because it
produces so much [ __ ] fat
um
i thought when i first read it i thought
he meant to like cook eggs which we did
camping yeah which is a nice very
old-school thing yeah
same pan the food freak could probably
weigh in on this but cooking using bacon
grease as cooking oil i think is i think
is the thing
and i know that if you cook something in
its own fat
that's that's referred to as
like you cook you cook it in its own fat
okay i could be wrong but i think that's
what it is
but i would use bacon grease for eggs
but for the bacon you just made you're
not like putting in a can
i don't know my my buddy rodney's mom
had it in a can and she used that as her
cooking oil we i think my mom puts it in
a can in the freezer and then disposes
of that now they pat it in a garage
freezer they added in a can on the stove
and i believe she would just take a
little spoonful of it like lard yeah
yeah like crisco whatever that is oh we
were a big crisco oh my mom's mom so my
mom makes the cutties i was saying it
was like vaseline or something i don't
know what it was i don't know
i thought it was ice cream for most of
my young life
i can't have that special ice cream and
why doesn't it need to be in the freezer
because the the cover looks really
advertised that cherry pie with the
cherry pie it's a bright blue yeah yeah
the only time i remember using it like
she remember she would like crisco down
pans or something for like baking maybe
and then also too that's what we that's
what we uh put in the fried daddy yeah
i think it's just oil yeah it's just
like hardened oh it's like fat i would
presume
but cooking bacon in bacon fat seems
pretty [ __ ] redundant yeah
but to each his own mm-hmm
uh this one's from adam
i haven't had one red yet is it garbage
to get a check for your birthday
gift where the giver says wait until the
end of the month to cash it and even
when you do the check still bounces oh
my god
that's a bad grandma right there jesus
i hated the [ __ ] getting a check as a
kid i want cash money it seems like such
a chore greenbacks let's [ __ ] go you
might as well give me a [ __ ] savings
bond i'm like i'm not gonna see the
benefit of this for [ __ ] weeks this
is the three to five businesses this was
the 90s i know three days as a kid that
was [ __ ] get 10 bucks 20 years
sentence yeah i would i remember at some
point my mom i started signing them over
to my mom sure and she would oh she'd
break you he'll break me off with the
cash yeah my paddy would still make me
wait and charge me an extra shipping and
handling fee
got what her body's check cash that's
three percent of [ __ ] 30. i would do
what's the glass wall in front of me do
you have an account here yet
that's a five dollar account
uh two forms id well you know me
okay where's my birth certificate mom
there was nothing like that that shit's
gone south but
if you went to a bank where they knew
you remember that well if you go in and
they know you you don't need id yeah
yeah i remember that back in the day
uh-huh or they'd cash it for you
if you didn't have an account there they
would they might cash it for you if they
know you uh-huh man we go in there like
hey there's [ __ ]
yeah
debbie that's pam what the [ __ ] that was
the kid what
yeah yeah yeah
uh i [ __ ] hate it i
also too like say i did get a check
from an ant or something for 50 bucks or
whatever it was if you give a check it's
got to be over a hundred dollars or a
hundred a hundred's a check sure
whatever say there's a hundred dollars
everything else has got to be
el dinero
cash money i remember i got married we
got
probably mostly maybe half checks really
yeah not from your friends
i don't know i i genuinely don't
remember to be honest with you there was
a handful of ch i don't remember there's
a handful of checks uh no not from like
[ __ ] pat wasn't cutting me a check
but phil x probably did she's a smart
guy he's gotta have a paper trail you
know what i mean i'm not paying pay a
[ __ ] tax on that he takes taxes out
of that he whis holds it for me
i know you're not gonna [ __ ] save
this 985 dollars and 38 cents can't
let's talk about ladder oh love that
ladder let's talk about ladder let's
talk about not leaving
the family in a lurch don't screw the
family all right don't you've ruined
enough holidays you've borrowed enough
money you've you've broken up enough
marriages don't scroll one last time on
your way out do yourself a favor go over
the ladder get yourself some term life
take care of the ones who take care of
you yeah that's pretty good copyright
that ladder is 100 digital no docs no
needles no paperwork when you apply for
three million coverage or less just
answer a few questions about your health
in an application just a few minutes a
phone or a laptop to apply ladder smart
algorithms work in real time so you find
out if you're instantly approved you
choose no hidden fees you can cancel any
time get a full refund if you change
your mind in the first 30 days finally
since life insurance costs more as you
age now's the time to cross it off your
list it is now here is the turkey pull
out that little phone of yours a little
laptop pick up the phone go to
ladderlife.com today to see if you're
instantly approved that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r-life dot com slash garbage
ladderlife.com garbage doing that back
to that show back to the show i remember
getting the checks
and i mean
tall i was in a financial position
hemmed as hemmed as you could be i just
had a flood pants on it i was hemmed up
and like running and i needed that three
to five plus these are a couple
different banking institutions it's not
like i'm taking some chase checks and
[ __ ]
a couple of [ __ ] citizens a couple of
[ __ ] whatevers wachovia
all kobe
with that first first credit union i
never trusted them at all
how to dump them into a [ __ ] td bank
account
so i was i remember being and i was a
lot of plates spitting on how quick
things were going to clear to pay the
rent to pay the whatever i remember the
next morning
rushing to the [ __ ] bank to get those
bits to get those suckers in it's like a
run keep keep [ __ ] the plate spinning
one more day you're outside of the
reception selling chili's gift cards for
50 cents on the dollar
yeah it's a bald kid over there in front
of wachovia given 50 cents on the dollar
got out there it's a wonderful life
that's where you get it from right
no it's just with dirtbags yeah okay you
never had somebody who had like a food
stamp card or something i'll give you 50
cents on the dollar i remember we were
at gamestop very early and gamestop
obviously notorious for their you know
shitty uh buy back whatever policy
um
this kid traded and saw her something
and it was my buddy and he was like i'm
just going to stand out front he's like
he had like 200 in store credit or
something
and we would we were like 11. like we
weren't like i was like you we could hop
in our own car and like go and be like
oh i'm going to do this like we were
children
and he was like i'm just going to hang
out front and just you know when people
walk in like hey what are you buying
give me the cash i'll put it on my store
credit i remember being like you're
going to get arrested really [ __ ]
quick trying to pull this scam is that
illegal though no but it's just weird
for an 11 year old to be standing there
being like you know doing a [ __ ]
three-card monty with you forward
forward thinking would you how all right
you're walking in as an adult
through a game stop just yeah i mean
you're obsessed with star wars don't act
like you you know you're into like
[ __ ] the s p 500 over here fair
enough okay
to a game stop to buy what more toys so
i'm wearing a flash t-shirt i got a
slurpee in my hand i'm walking into a
game stop okay and the guy or anywhere a
best buy and there's a kid out front any
kid i'm not that's what i'm saying the
only thing with the kid i'll do is
drifter just give him money
what i would just get like that's even
weirder i feel now
like when the kids come up with the
candy that's different here you go you
get here's five bucks go ahead i would
never do business with a child that's
what i'm saying that's insane it seems
grifty i don't trust you where'd you get
that receipt i don't [ __ ] know you
where your parents have yeah somebody
should be telling you you shouldn't be
doing this yeah you can't be exchanging
goods and services with a miner no no no
no no you give him a twin guy can't get
out of here whatever you would give a
kid outside of a best buy 20 bucks and
say hey get out of here if he was him
hey if they had some sob story and
someone was filming yeah
i'm a good guy
as soon as the cameras are give me a
little [ __ ]
give me that final fantasy too [ __ ]
hold on let's do it again let's do one
more take let's do one more take
really sell it this time kid
yeah yeah i don't know i would that just
i steer clear i'd be like i don't i'm
not getting in bed
because you ha i i feel you haven't made
a lot of definitely can't do that you
haven't
you haven't made a lot of good decisions
that you're 11 year old here doing some
store credit cash scheme well no i don't
know if the k the parents definitely
didn't make something that's what i'm
saying
there's the wrong turns that's something
to think this 11 year old thinks it's
okay to stand out front and pedal store
credit
and let me wet my beak a little bit hey
you saved 10 bucks oh you're sitting
there negotiating like yeah do 50 50. i
was smoking
i'm just saying
i don't think you're going to get in
there on the transaction it's going to
go as smoothly as you anticipate there's
going to be some [ __ ] roadblocks when
you get in there and talk to an official
gamestop employee who got you a little
ronnie
this gamestop's been closed for 20 years
yeah it's tough
um this one's from chris
10 homie first time is it garbage to
take a doggie bag home from a wedding
that's [ __ ] how do you feel about
this they encourage it
but the centerpieces everybody takes
home a centerpiece
did that [ __ ] ever make it out of the
hotel
i don't know ivory i i those little bags
of jordan almonds can kick rocks too i
don't really hate it those things
i think i've remember my mom maybe a
couple of times taking one and b and
even being like what are you do you
can't just take that that belongs no
they want you i know i know i know
because they pay money for it or
whatever yeah so it's like yeah they're
ours take them and i guess
specifically flowers or something right
yes flowers centerpiece yeah i guess it
sits at the house for two three days and
you throw it out but
i mean taking it back to a hotel and
then from the hotel to the car the car
to the house i got all this luggage now
if you're driving home from the wedding
if it's a local wedding
i'll give you that yeah if it's in the
city and you're living the burbs you pop
in you take it hop in the car drive home
i'll give you that but
transferring free [ __ ] from uh from
anywhere bothers me doggie bag at a
wedding is super trash
yes you got to think because you got to
think the night's not over after dinner
they clear the plates they put out the
coffee everyone gets a piece of the cake
the dance the pop that is that then
there's the after party
bar
for the next four hours do they offer do
you want us to i've never been at a
wedding when they go do you want me to
wrap this get the [ __ ] out of here
never
that's insane
uh-uh take a piece of cake home maybe
yeah that i get but then like what are
you putting the steak and asparagus in
there with the cake that's a bad look
the cake i get
because they'll even box it up for you
and be like you as you're walking by
there's like
they'll have like you know 50 pieces of
box cake there you know what the
ultimate trash to go is the two plates
on top of each other like a flying
saucer hold on shout out to [ __ ]
chicken holiday it used to be in like
langhorne or levittown
they used to give they used chicken
holidays all right
i don't know what that [ __ ] means
but i just picture a chicken somewhere
down in puerto vallarta
a couple of drinks in them
just trying to get coke
just taking it easy chicken holidays all
right oh for me it was kippy in a cabana
with a 12 piece uh that's all right
both of these are okay chicken holidays
in my book but i'd have to be british to
call it a holiday edna hello
um
chicken holidays it was a chicken place
you know like a [ __ ] wings to go
whatever like the you know a fried chick
one of those fried chicken places
chicken holiday i'm sure you can find it
or something about it and dude the
chicken finger platter
was like it seemed like 15 pounds of
french fries 100 pounds of chicken and
they would cram it down with two paper
plates and staple it and that's that was
the goat and like dude the fries would
be sticking out the side one would be
stapled it was [ __ ] all right as a
kid man
my dad said we were going to chicken
holiday clear the calendar boys
they put on a decent honey mustard and
barbecue sauce i didn't [ __ ] with it
back then i was straight up and down
that a two liter of coke get out of the
way i love a honey muss
a good one are you looking up chicken
holiday i am this place looks oh it's
still there
i doubt it's still there they've got a
couple locations buddy sure are they in
pence is it a pennsylvania thing are
they like all over town it's a new
jersey thing okay this one was in pa
they crossed the river there you go i
assumed it was probably like a local
small friend like a you know a
few guys that owned it or whatever yeah
it was like a kennedy fried chicken type
place yeah on their stinks on there it
was nicer this was like a night like a
on their website they have all their
reviews like posted like like
highlighting their reviews right they're
all me they're literally all kevin
it's all five stars awesome as usual a
plus plus and then one two star review
from patricia my four dollar coleslaw
was forgotten
which i get that is too stark
i mean it's a holiday you can't be
worried a lot going on somebody forget
your coleslaw it's all right i like it
dude it's ten reviews and eight of them
are from kevin
that's awesome
wait really the name kevin swear to god
all right
this is great he can't write this [ __ ]
i'll put that in his fat court file
case closed on this porker uh-huh
it's probably never staple in you
squeeze you in a plate
uh this one's from tom um
is it garbage to bring a kfc family meal
complete with sides to the beach for
lunch yes
100
the beach is a is a
it can go bad quickly on what you're
eating acceptable foods to be eaten on
the beach
which we've touched on but never maybe
made a formal list it's tough because
hot dog sandwiches did you guys not just
see what just happened what this guy's
question is about a chicken holiday it's
true checking on the beach my god it is
sometimes i think there's like
somebody else writing this [ __ ] there's
like a bigger
force right in this show that's wild
we're just living some simulation and in
the next room over there's another
podcast where that didn't happen
make the fat one fart yeah
you didn't coordinate that that just
happened no i brought up chicken holiday
organically and then i saw there was
another chicken one so i brought that up
i didn't realize it was a chicken a
chicken on a holiday wow yeah
yeah you can't do it man
anything that the sand could get in but
this is tough because
this is my this is how i struggle in
life a lot with
your hands are inherently sandy at the
beach
yeah but you only eat with
or there's you know your hands are
predisposed to be sandy at the beach but
you only want to eat things with your
hand at the beach typically
yeah sandwich
hot dog pretzels cheese pretzels bags of
chips burgers where are you getting good
i made up burgers hot dogs
um sandwich hoagies hoagies hoagie is
really the
the beach food we'll do pizza too which
isn't bad because they'll deliver down
on the beach okay just call up hey i'm
on [ __ ] sam's sams doesn't deliver
but you go hey i'm on 14th street beach
and whoever they'll like just come and
you just look they'll walk off that's
not bad um
especially because we're such a huge
crew at the beach and so it's like just
get [ __ ] six pizzas and everybody
will [ __ ] some fries from curly's
fries out
some place also does uh
funnel cake french fries which is
wild what i don't know what they are
this is just strips of dough maybe but
it's like a little more savory as well
like i don't know what kind of fry
things i don't know maybe it's french
fries dipped in uh funny
i don't think so it might just be the
shape i'm not sure but for some whatever
it is even if it is the shape oh wait a
minute oh it's shaped like a funnel cake
shaped like a french fry oh
okay i don't know if it's just strips of
[ __ ] dough toby's on the case it's
strips instead of making the whole
funnel cake they just do like fry shaped
okay and then they pep same thing
powdered sugar something to dump dunk it
in yeah but it is more
savory i don't know if they salt it a
little more or something it's a little
more hot
either way i mean
it's pretty good yeah i remember one of
the kids came back with i'm like wow one
of those are like funnel cake french
fries and i was like yo what the [ __ ]
did you just get over here you little
[ __ ] go get yourself some [ __ ] here's
20. huh
um
i think kfc across the board is not good
kfc's tough anything with knives and
forks i would agree with sides what
would you need to sell you're going to
[ __ ] you're sitting there first of all
it shouldn't be
any hot food on the beach is a tough
look you can't
mash potatoes and gravy on the [ __ ]
beach if you have a [ __ ] heat stroke
yeah it's wild that's [ __ ] nuts don't
do that
that's wild
pizza's alright because it cools quickly
if it's a delivered dot it's you know
relative that's as hot as i'll go a hot
dog maybe but lasagna is good no you're
nuts um
but
yeah it's tough i remember i saw one guy
this was last year two years ago this
guy brought
lunch meat and made his own sandwich on
the beach and i was like that's
[ __ ] i think you thought it was crazy
crazy
there has to be sand in there it has to
be your make you're peeling like pieces
of turkey and cheese and you think
sand's really small but when a piece is
in your mouth it'll be chewing a [ __ ]
boulder oh
you'll hear it yeah
you get sometimes they get muscles or
clams [ __ ] for a week
uh you know what we did uh last time i
went down the beach which felt pretty
classy because denise is you know
getting older right you know she we go
down to the beach and she
now if it's just her or a small crew
like me it was me my wife and her
and uh
she'll pay for them to come down and put
a
uh
umbrella in now it's like 10 bucks for
the day
20 bucks for the day because they have
like rentals on the beach you can run an
umbrella
you can rent a chair or like a [ __ ]
car or whatever they have like a little
station like every couple of blocks she
comes down she's young kids you know
what i mean they're like college kids or
high school kids
hits them with the 20 they put it in you
leave it there you just walk away you
don't have to [ __ ] do anything at
five o'clock they just come back and
pick it up i like it it's very nice
but i felt like a little i felt like a
little bit of a [ __ ] there's this kid
[ __ ]
i'm sitting there like hey you know
where the chips at
i know but as a man he's infringing on
my manhood that's the man's duty to put
that in i like that now it's like
another mowing another man's lawn the
less you got to do on the beach the
better
i hate all that [ __ ] drives me crazy
i don't do it
pay a nice little pool boy to do it for
you there you go pair of tight shorts
hachimachi
um all right let's do like a couple more
here this is from gary 20 stockholder
here no big deal never have on read but
has yours or someone else's mother ever
shown up to your wedding with two dates
what which is crazy
i don't even understand that
it's like pre-season football they're
competing for the job
i want to see how you do the electric
slide then i'll make my decision two
guys wearing red pennies
that's crazy i mean i could see
i can't see anything around that
although polyamory is uh polyamory and
that's what it's called is becoming more
of a thing
really the multiple people in a
relationship yeah yeah yeah
swingers
not with those old schoolers though
two dates this is
what
i don't know man i don't get it but also
you know to each their own i guess yeah
enjoy yourselves that would be weird
that's weird to know your mom's
dating two guys at the same who were
cool with it i guess
that's strange that's wacky wild stuff
broadly is a party though i guess
definitely definitely taking leftovers
from there yeah
put her between two blades
staple them
chicken holiday pretty good uh this
one's from andrew is your is it garbage
to have a bidet that doesn't heat the
water rather just shoots the cold water
from the toilet line onto your butt i
didn't know that the day's heated the
water was heated
i think there's a i think there's some
uh you know
less in-depth ones that you just [ __ ]
hook to the tank and you know it's just
like uh just squirts the cleat like
fresh water okay that you would like
flush the you know toilet with or
whatever okay uh less invasive ones and
then there's like the big ones that you
look and they got which i
the days in a public-ish restroom are
wild to me
you know what i mean oh that's wait
no
they're not really what oh they have
been hotels yeah you're right okay some
hotels are like you know uh
certain podcast studios that we go to
that have them not clean water though
right it's just toilet water but before
it gets to the toilet it's fresh water
okay yeah yeah it's not coming from the
tank in the toilet yeah but that would
still be fresh water but oh really yeah
where do you think that comes from
that's what's water you can drink
in the back of the toilet you can drink
that water yeah i mean i don't recommend
it but yeah i thought the only dirt from
that water is that's in the tank that's
clean water
that's the same water as the sink
really see i thought that there was
pipes for toilet water and shower water
and then pipes for drinking water really
yeah it's all pipes baby uh no it's all
the same water it is yeah huh
uh-huh damn i didn't know that so like a
copper pipe will run into the bathroom
and then split go to the
toilet go to the shower and go to the
sink so the only place the water is not
drinkable is actually in the toilet bowl
right
not sure this is for future reference
for you or something um i didn't know
that i thought that water was
not as good as
it's regular fresh clean water
all right yeah and then when it goes
down it goes down to the i believe they
call that the sanitary line
it goes down the poop chute yeah which
is also the same water that goes in the
same thing from the sink from the
and it all goes it all it's one in and
one ounce and it all goes back to the
water treatment plant that i don't get
and i don't want to talk about it
because it makes me think i'm drinking
poop water that's why i'm all all right
let's check i don't understand that
that's why you got to get the goddamn
water filter i'm [ __ ] telling you all
right man we'll stop drinking out of the
toilet that's a [ __ ] start you don't
need a water filter
i don't i don't get other people's
bidets that's too intimate to me that's
too weird
like a little butthole using someone
else's
it's just like a water fountain man but
for you
into like your most
intimate spot and that means that's been
in someone else's [ __ ] to me as well
that's like reusing someone's butt plug
you consider your butt your most
intimate spot mine's my earlobes
i cheat my cheek you don't get over here
i'll give you a little nibby kiss my
neck
[Laughter]
i would say the nipple is the most
intimate spot that's sensitive nipples
aren't intimate you show your nipples to
everybody i got nipples
it's on my credit card
that's her how do i know this is you
to find out i don't uh
i just that's why it's crossing the line
to me a little bit
i don't know man
it's spraying your [ __ ] it's spraying
your poopy [ __ ]
that to me
if somebody goes hey man
this is the way i look at it detach it
from the toilet if someone goes hey man
this is the thing i use to reach around
and spray my [ __ ] with it does you
want to hold it or do you want to use it
to go absolutely [ __ ] it does have
toothbrush vibes
yes thank you it's like that's yours i
don't want to i don't want to you know
would you shower in someone else's
shower though
yeah that's completely different
not [ __ ] first
yeah not upside down specifically for
your [ __ ] and [ __ ] is different
you're not technically washing [ __ ] out
of your ass crack
when you're showering you know what i
mean i am
i'm sure yeah
obviously there's that's not the main
use for it you know what i mean you're
washing your hair
[Laughter]
just for jerking off do you
[Music]
yeah the shower to me is weight grosser
get a little wet work really
that's nice that's nuts that's crazy
uh-uh it's in the toilet first of all
this thing is in the toilet
sure
yeah it's just a hose
blowing up your butthole
yeah that other people use are you even
a bidet man
when have you used a bidet i've been to
europe quite a number of never used a
bidet yeah it's all right no and i
didn't see any when i was in paris
yeah i don't think they have them in
hostels
i wasn't in the hospital because the
charles the fifth hotel in the fourth
year in dc mall
okay everyone knows he was the worst
charles
it's either four or six they closed
they caught him chuck
they tried to kick him out of the family
he had to start and open his own hotel
to make ends meet this [ __ ] guy
um all right let's see here this one's
from tommy b
never have one red how many meals have
you eaten naked which i feel was a you
thing sure
sure yeah
um
that last the last blowout that i had in
the one hotel right before boston i was
brought up on charges i don't know if i
was in boston
that wild order was in boston and those
charges in fat court didn't stick you
shook the quesadilla and the blueberry
pancakes
i think that was boston completely naked
completely naked
that i can kind of get but what do you
get up to that well where did they
didn't deliver to the door hotels don't
do that so you went down clothed unless
you went down naked this is what i don't
get i'm not necessarily opposed to it
but i went there there's a series of i
went down there with clothes on got the
food came out the elevator took my
clothes off set it up
and then got completely naked moved the
the desk chair over right in front of
the tv between the the
the bed set the ironing board up put it
put a couple chafing dishes out that's
exactly what i did
yeah you put the ironing board up but
you put it all the way down so it's like
a little table
now myself a little time there
sat naked my little my little stinger
hanging out yeah i don't get that that's
uh it was like
i wanted to be like completely free and
like be completely
my disgusting glutton self
i was in a real dark place
this guy is [ __ ] up
[Laughter]
yikes but that's the psychology behind
it
sure yeah yeah that's i don't have that
disgustingness or whatever i would be
naked more if it was socially acceptable
it is not i want to go on the record
we have a strong you closed policy here
at tutti tutti tutti inc or whatever i
wasn't making people
that should be our law that should be
our next venture start a law firm or
accountant territory in turitori
like i even
i felt uncomfortable on the camping trip
when i had my shirt off was i grossing
you guys out when i had my shirt off you
were very comfortable yeah
yeah because i also said was that gross
and yet because i know you said you
couldn't finish your chipotle that one
time when i was when i came back from
the gym and i was all sweaty yeah that's
totally different is it you were
dripping in
you came in like yeah you were eating
and it was like drips on the table that
was a little different in
a weird hotel room that had a dining
room so when we're in the right setting
i can feel comfortable to have my shirt
off around you guys
listen this is my take on it um
the rights but this is you push the the
the boundary of right setting
that's that's my beef with the right
setting is your hotel room you should
have your shirt off
everywhere else everywhere else your
shirt should be on my shirt's usually
off at the house
yeah so i don't come over
that's why you're not allowed in my
house well if you came over i would put
my shirt on i don't know
yeah
okay so you
since you have lost the weight
um
you now can lift you put your belly in
your pants yeah it's no longer under but
now the belly's in the pants it's a
tough transitional and along the side it
creates these
valleys i would call them
at this crevasses
two grand canyons screaming down the
side right to your
your johnson
and at the right angle in the right
lighting with the right whatever
i can see a little too much down there
okay i don't want to see nothing i don't
want to see but it's just like
you want to see a little bit oh listen
you can take your shirt off when someone
else has their shirt off that's the new
rule how about that all right
i feel like that's a normal hey we're
going to the pool
we're you know we're changing we're in a
green room at a show and i'm going to
change my shirt cool we're all getting
ready whatever
other than that
your clothes stay on socks as well socks
and shoes as well why
your feet aren't good
why do you do them a lot well you go i
got great feet i do have great feet you
haven't seen them in years apparently
that's not true i'm looking at them
right now right now what does that even
mean
right now
first of all they're under a table you
have shoes and you have some that's how
much i have a camera down there that's
how much you'll lie to prove a point um
i need i need to i need to go see the
girls i need i need to get a patty
okay and get some some scraping done
but at heart i have beautiful feet they
just need [ __ ] tools to shape at
heart they're good kids
yeah they made a couple of babies just
need a chance yeah maybe an after school
program pcb has a great joke uh oh yeah
how long has she goes
how long have your feet been smoking
cigarettes people have bad feet it's a
good piece of [ __ ] shut up casey baby
she's over there on the edinburgh fringe
if you're over there go check her out
check out casey big we got to wrap it up
here gang okay this has been a fun one a
nice little family episode good time
love you love you too buddy guys check
out
check out a [ __ ] live show we're
going to be all over the [ __ ] we're
cooking baby come see us our selling out
we're moving some tickets uh
this live shows are a good time me and
the big man co headline we come back out
we play ayg with the crowd it's [ __ ]
cuckoo bananas wanna see you there love
yous see you next week peace